hello I'm Gareth James I'm a faculty
member at the USC Marshall School of
Business and I'm also one of the
co-authors on the introduction to
statistical learning book
hi I'm Daniella Whitton and I'm a
professor at University of Washington
and I'm also a co-author on introduction
to statistical learning
and uh Trevor and Rob have asked us to
present the section on multiple
hypothesis testing so we're very excited
aren't we Daniela oh I'm excited this is
this is extra fun for both me and Gareth
because a very very long time ago we
were both PhD students of Robin Travers
I was a student of Rob's Gareth was a
student of Trevor and if you're
wondering what Rob and Trevor are like
in real life then I can tell you Rob is
exactly the way he comes across
um in these recordings like he's just
like a very friendly big teddy bear
Gareth what's Trevor like
pretty much the same way close this is
this is kind of like the uh old days
actually doing sort of Labor unpaid for
your advisor so but seriously we're very
excited about the session and then I I
think it's a very important topic so uh
we're looking forward to uh presenting
it yeah multiple testing
um is a topic that I really love to talk
about because
um
it kind of isn't as flashy as some of
the topics in introduction to
statistical learning multiple testing
and really hypothesis testing in general
is something that's been pretty well
understood in statistics for quite a
while but it's really important and um
if you if you misunderstand hypothesis
testing and in particular if you mess up
your multiple testing you can very
quickly end up in a situation where you
have spurious findings that aren't going
to be reproducible that aren't going to
hold up to further scrutiny and so um
really understanding the fundamentals of
multiple hypothesis testing is just
incredibly important to to performing
any type of data analysis or statistical
learning and multiple hypothesis
testings being around as a sort of
classical idea for a long time but it's
become increasingly important with the
Advent of enormous data sets so instead
of doing uh three or four multiple
hypothesis tests we're now doing tens of
thousands or even larger numbers and so
the issues that are associated with
multiple hypothesis testing have just
become larger and larger and there's
been a big research field over the last
20 or 30 years on addressing some of
those issues and we're looking forward
to presenting some of that material here
all right you want to get started Gary
yeah so uh I'm gonna make a start by
talking about just what is multiple
hypothesis testing and then Danielle is
going to give a very quick overview of
the basics of hypothesis testing we're
going to assume here that most of you
have seen a standard hypothesis test
before so that'll just be a sort of
review of those ideas and then we'll go
through and talk about some of the
classical methods for addressing
hypothesis testing and then finally
Daniel is going to finish up with some
of the more modern approaches but first
of all let's uh let's talk about what is
multiple hypothesis testing so I'm sure
most of you are familiar with the idea
of a standard single hypothesis test
where we might be trying to test say a
null hypothesis like expected blood
pressures of mice and the control and
treatment groups are equal versus an
alternative that they're not equal and
we know how to do that so Gareth what
does that say on the slide each with a
little zero under it so so H Sub Zero
that's the uh that's represents the null
hypothesis and then we usually have an H
sub 1 or an H sub a to represent the
alternative hypothesis so what how do
you pronounce it h Sub Zero
this is in case you're wondering in the
audience we we actually had an argument
about this like two years ago so this is
just an opportunity for you to see that
I'm right at least if you have an
American accent those of you with
different accents all bets are off yeah
and Daniella and I almost never have
arguments but occasionally so how do you
pronounce it though you haven't told
them
uh o
oh I say h naught and Gareth says
something else that's hard to say with
an American accent h0 you say h naught
oh okay all right not on video okay
okay and then the the topic for today's
session is when we have not just one
hypothesis test but let's call it m
different hypothesis tests and as I
mentioned historically we've had values
of M like three or four and had to deal
with relatively small numbers like that
but these days we're often trying to
deal with values of M and the tens of
thousands are even larger and just as
one example on the slide here we have H
naught zero the expected value of the
jth biomarker among mice and the control
and treatment groups and so the idea
here is that we might have many many
thousands of biomarkers we're interested
in testing for a difference in each one
of those biomarkers between the control
and treatment groups and once we do that
everything becomes a lot more
complicated than when we're dealing with
a single null hypothesis and the biggest
issue is that it's very very easy to end
up with very large number of false
positives situations where we reject the
null hypothesis conclude that there's
something interesting happening when
it's really just a function of the large
number of tests that we're doing so I'm
going to turn it over to Daniella now
and she can give you a quick overview of
hypothesis testing in general
okay so hypothesis tests this is just
like a a quick reminder because we are
sort of assuming you've seen some of
this before but basically hypothesis
test gives us a way to answer a yes or
no question so for example is the true
coefficient beta J in a linear
regression model equal to zero or does
the expected blood pressure among mice
in the treatment group equal the
expected blood pressure among mice in
the control group
so when we conduct a hypothesis test
there are four major steps first we're
going to define the null hypothesis
which I call H naught and Gareth is
being kind of cagey about how he
pronounces it but he pronounces it
differently and also the alternative
hypothesis I'll talk more about what
those mean in a couple minutes we're
then going to construct a test statistic
that is going to quantify something
about the data
the aspect of the data that we're
interested in the strength of the data
how much it tells us about the null
hypothesis
then we're going to compute the p-value
and finally we're going to use that
p-value to decide whether or not to
reject the null hypothesis
so what do each of these steps mean
all right well the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to divide the
world into a null hypothesis and an
alternative hypothesis so the null
hypothesis H naught is really boring it
is just the default state of belief
about the world the null hypothesis
tells us that nothing interesting is
happening nothing to see here and move
along so for example maybe the null
hypothesis for a linear regression model
is that the true coefficient beta J
equals zero
or maybe the null hypothesis is that
there's no difference in the expected
blood pressure between mice and the
control group and mice in the treatment
group
so the null hypothesis is is super
boring and it's like if if the null
hypothesis holds then it's like okay
it's sort of like the default situation
and that's what we start off by
believing uh we start by assuming the
novel is true and look at the data to
see if the data can convince us that we
should switch from the null to the
alternative right exactly
so the alternative hypothesis tells us
that there's something different or
unexpected going on so the alternative
hypothesis that would be something
surprising something interesting it's
what we want to discover so for example
maybe the alternative hypothesis is the
true coefficient beta J in the linear
regression model is non-zero or maybe
the alternative hypothesis is that
there's a difference between the
expected blood pressure of mice in the
control group and mice in the treatment
group I sometimes think of this in terms
of uh criminal trial where we have a
null hypothesis that the defendant is
not guilty they haven't committed a
crime and the alternative is that they
have committed a crime and the default
Assumption of course at least in the US
is that uh people are innocent until
proven guilty so we believe the null
hypothesis unless evidence sort of
Beyond Reasonable Doubt is presented to
the contrary right
so the next thing we're going to do is
construct the test statistic and the
test statistic summarizes the extent to
which our data are consistent with h
naught
so for example going with wanting to see
if the expected blood pressure and the
treatment mice is the same as the
expected blood pressure and the control
mice we can let Muti hat be the observed
average so the sample mean of the blood
pressures in among the treatment mice
and NT is the number of treatment mice
and similarly muhatsi is the sample mean
for the blood pressure and the control
mice and NC is the number of mice in the
control group
so to test the null hypothesis that mu T
equals mu C in other words the null
hypothesis that the population mean of
the blood pressure in the treatment and
control groups is equal we're going to
construct what's known as a two-sample t
statistic and we're calling it capital T
so there's a numerator and a denominator
the numerator is just the difference
between the sample mean and the
treatment group minus the sample mean in
the control group
and then the denominator is something
that's sort of like not terribly
important for us right now but it
basically you can think about it as like
the basically it's the standard
deviation of the numerator it's an okay
way to think about that denominator yeah
and so T is basically telling us how
many standard deviations we are away
from zero uh so a number like one is not
surprising a number like three or four
might be pretty surprising if the null
is true so like if there were no noise
in our data
then we would expect mu T hat to be
exactly equal to Mu C hat if the null
was true if the null was true right but
in real life even if the null is true mu
T hat minus PC hat isn't going to be
exactly equal to zero and so T will tend
to be pretty big either very large or
very small if the null hypothesis does
not hold but if the null hypothesis
holds we'd expect T to be like not too
big an absolute value
but one of the problems with the test
statistic is that we don't actually know
necessarily what counts as a large or a
small value intuitively the further that
this is away from zero the more
information we have or more suspicious
we become about the null hypothesis but
uh the p-value is what's going to help
help us make a final decision whether we
believe the null or not Gareth you're
jumping the gun that's on the next slide
I was just trying to preview what was
coming next right okay so the next thing
we're going to do is compute the p-value
and so the p-value is one of I think if
I had to say I don't know what Gareth
thinks but like the the most
misunderstood idea and statistics
yeah there's so many it's actually kind
of a race to the bottom but I do think
that this one would win that race to the
bottom so the p-value like I would say
like 90 of p-value definitions that I
see written are like not correct I think
this definition is correct what do you
think Gareth I think we're good yeah
we'll check with Trevor and Rob
afterwards you know they're going to
start busting into this recording to let
us know we got it wrong no I'm just
kidding guys we got it right the p-value
is the probability of observing a test
statistic at least as Extreme as what we
observed if H naught holds
yeah and this is this is key that it's
under the assumption that the null
hypothesis is true uh sometimes the
p-value is misinterpreted as something
like the probability that the null
hypothesis is true which is absolutely
not correct right so the p-value is
telling me if we live in a universe
where the null hypothesis holds then How
likely are we to see such a big value of
the test statistic either very big or
very small if it's a two-sided p-value
come on so a small p-value provides
evidence against H naught and the reason
it gives us evidence against H naught
again is because this is the probability
of seeing such an extreme value of the
test statistic if the null hypothesis
holds so if that probability is very
very small then there's a good chance
maybe the null hypothesis doesn't hold
well at least very suspicious right that
we should be suspicious
so in the example of our treatment mice
and control mice where we're very
concerned about whether their blood
pressures are different if our T
statistic equals 2.33
that in order to interpret that 2.33 we
need to know something about what the T
statistic would look like under the null
hypothesis and it turns out that under
the null hypothesis that t statistic
would have a normal 0 1 distribution or
at least approximately approximately
approximately a normal zero one
distribution and that is what is shown
here that yellow distribution here is
the normal zero one distribution
and the blue line shows you the The
observed test statistic of 2.33
so now we can say okay well under the
null hypothesis we would expect our T
statistics to fall anywhere in that
yellow distribution and in fact it kind
of is like way out at the edge of the
yellow distribution so we're a bit
surprised here yeah I'm becoming a
little bit suspicious that this null
hypothesis might not hold
and in fact here the p-value equals 0.02
because under the null distribution
we're only going to see a t statistic
that's this large and absolute value two
percent of the time so 0.02 corresponds
to 2 percent
so there's two possibilities here either
the null hypothesis is true and we just
got kind of unlucky with this test
statistic and that happens one in every
50 times we perform a hypothesis test or
one at every 50 times because of two
percent because of the two percent
exactly so two percent is one over fifty
so if we perform this hypothesis test 50
times and the null hypothesis was true
each time we might expect about once to
get a t statistic this extreme right so
the other possibility of course here is
that the null hypothesis is not true
right
so how should we interpret a p-value of
0.02 I mean it's a matter of like how
surprised are you by a one in 50 event
if a 1 in 50 event is like well I mean
that could happen if you did it 50 times
it would happen once then you shouldn't
think that a p-value of 0.02 is too
compelling right because that's just a
two percent chance right so so this
doesn't in any way guarantee that the
null hypothesis is false on the other
hand one in 50 is a relatively unusual
occurrence but the concept here is that
the smaller that that p-value is the
more sure we feel that the null
hypothesis is in is in fact not true
exactly